when we play you will hear the crowd you
don't even have to hear them you can
feel them it's like a rumble we get so
much energy from the people
the feeling it gives you think relevant
I think a lot of our inspiration comes
from our youth growing up and late 80s
like there's this huge collection of
sounds and memories that I draw from but
inspiration can be anything remember the
last time we were here Thank You skip
tonight it's kinda hard to say why we
are driven we had a big rise in
popularity and then you see other people
doing it and then we're thinking okay
what's the next thing and it's a
constant challenge you know he started
it
reinventing what you do every so many
months and I think one of the strongest
parts of our show if anything the idea
that whoever's in the crowd feels at one
point that we're playing a song
especially for them the most
constructive way for us to work is
indeed to not start creatively together
but complement each other along the way
one project can be more Mike and other
can be more me it's the United creative
vision that is the final product
I think Dimitri's perseverance is the
quality I look up to mostly and my
brother it's Mike's creativity you love
what you do we're driven people
so you wake up in the morning and it's
not like what do I have to do
now what can I do today
[Music]
you